c'est pas grave c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave il a mis du
temps on y va dou tout
doucement monte un chouille ou pas mon
chouille
et on continue et on efface on est
d'accord ouais par
exemple
vasy oh le pain les morceaux de pain
c'est génial les baguette mais c'est
top oh les bateaux c'est génial génial
génial oh les calbas c'est
tout
allezp
allez
moteur
ça
av tu peux monter un peu
peut-êtreir plus les bateaux plus les
bateaux tu
vois changer unu plan que tu as fait
tout à l'heure super beau ça regarde
[Musique]
regardeisseement doucement qu'il est le
temps de dzomer doucement doucement
doucement doucement c'est super beau
ça il a pas eu le temps de
descendre vas-y avance avance
fait tout le tour du P ou pas ouais par
exemple vas-y vas-y
vas-y oh ça Bou dans tous les sens c'est
top les bagnoles qui passent derrière le
bordel on prend un peu moins d'eau un
peu moins
d'eau c'est quoi ça ça c'est des cal
basses est top je fa tout à l'heure est
top à la même distance ouis
ouais la vie dans le la vie dans le dans
le port c'est génial personne ne regarde
c'est
top avec les fr devant et tout la vache
génial du port
là génial génial génial
génial
un tout petit
peu continuer devantou tu peonter
suivir à gauche c'est moin
spectaculaire
la rue c'est bien avec la rue regarde la
r pas prendre la Rueil les bateaux quand
même dans le
champ
génialve parti de la vie ça tu
sais trs
léger
ir toême faire plan lar
ok
dis est
ven je pas
TEPP je te
rappelle beaucoup de choses à sujet
ouais j'aimerais bien qu'il fasse
quelques plan je en les pas de main de
tout ce bordel de bateau quand tu vois
que tu vois à ta droite là c'est
extraordinaire quand tu tombes là-dedans
c'est
suffoquant ça va fr bien et toi voilà on
peut s'arrêter là à mon avis
tu pe à droite à droite on va les faire
après je
propose je sa je comm rest comme
ça c'est quoi au fond à gauche c'est la
mosquée
ou je
l'eau
un
pe pas
trsè dou très
doucement
re Le Blan sur la mosquée
vas-y pass Le Blan
derrière tell B ce
matin
la
allez les plan des bateaux qui la foule
la foule qui bouge dans tous les
sens tu peux pas sortir voilà voil là il
y a plus rien plus de l'eau
ok
merci magnifique tour
tour tour ça tourne ça
tourne regarde les bateaux regarde ça
comme plan de de regarde le bateau à
voile et
tout garde
garde pas souffler avance TR viment tout
doucement
voilà un peu large encore
magnifique
GM un peu
[Musique]
non la lumière arrive la lumière arrive
sign que la lumière arrive méfiez-vous
avance comme ça avance comme ça
mais là tu enfin bon tu pouras pas faire
ce qu'on voulait faire moi la làrouver
bloqué au bout mais non au bout on part
à droite areou sais pas comment il va
faire pour se pour le rattraper tu es
vachement loin à droite est très très
bon
arrêtez les mecs
est un petit peu vite devant à mon avis
aussi mais c'est pas grave tu vois ce
que je dire regarde c'est clair tu vois
maintenant il
est d'accord un peu vite devantou il
fallait monter c'est pas que je voulais
faire on pe le REF
ouis ouais c'est pour t'aer par que
c'estement il est là-bas il est derrière
mais là mais là tu en a un autre curieux
voilà l'ment il va être sublime à droite
il y a peut-être une petite vibration là
il y a du vent tu m'étonnes
ouais il y a vibration
ouais fa chier ça fait chier fait chier
faut la mettre en side cette de
boule
voilà voilà voilà doucement doucementil
c'est il est là donc c'est pas de
vibration là on s'en fout
voilàter un tout petit
peu voil c'est là il faut monter
doucement voil c'est là c'est làù
c'est bord tu restes un peu làdans
prends le temps de regarder ça
làdans drapeau tout ça les gens qui
travaillent tu laiss vivre ça un petit
peu regarde un
bordel
tu pe y
aller le pain à droit tu vois les
baguettes à droite c'est une folie ça
les
[Musique]
baguettes Vy
coupe regarde un peu cette vie qu'il a
làans c'est
top
alors est-ce qu'on peut monter un petit
peu s'il te
plaît faire çaend je te laisse faire ça
il n regarde un peu je pense qu' mon
temps il regard un peu moins vas-y je te
laisse
faire
peux monter couopain j'arrive je termine
je par reste sur un
[Musique]
fix couper
je tour tu restes là franc s'il te
plaît c'est devenu super convivi à bord
s'il te plaît
s'il te plaît r s'il te plaît Fran on
reste là ouais mais c'est pour les fa
c'est cool
[Musique]
qu monte un
chouille il a pas dit s'il te plaît ais
je suis d'accord je le fais quand même
oh le pain c'est
génial voilà voilà attends on reste par
là er ça ouais ouais vas-y voilà
par rentre un peu dans les bateaux
derrière c'est génial regarde ce plan il
est extraordinaire ce plan ça vie ça
c'est génial j'adore
ça de pas trop prendre le coin des
maisons à
droite ta gauche s'il te
plaît les mais tu vois garde toujours
même
rest une HE
çaff j' encore un
dernier fait un planici ou pas en large
entier ou pas contre
joli
le mec il se casse la gueule
[Musique]
avec
la tourne
'estenlève les rafales parce que
vraiment 3002 c'est quoi c'est la
vitesse euh ouais es fou mais non mais
il est en priorité
di en combien tu en
500 250 pas
possible 25 on paser on va rester comme
ça
d'accord
priorité comment tu
Bou
4 un truc comme
ça la molette
[Musique]
devant
trs très
très
le bordel làdans c'est quelque chose
c'est vraiment l'endroit marchant c'est
du
trucz
ot du
[Musique]
bateau moment S
pasiè
est déjà
sparé la partie à gauche parti
[Musique]
droite à gauche oui je
voiséroport on
[Musique]
prest
elle est où elle est dans le B droit en
haut droit
virage ah oui
ou n
[Musique]
ça c'est beau tuas
ça grâ au
pilote sur pilote la
vach
surile avec un opérateur rien
faire je dis il Ren la BAL tous les
deux trop mign tous les
deus est les
de dit qu'on est bien qu'on est bon si
si on est là c'est grâce à vous ben
exactement
[Musique]
oui pouri tu veux en descendre tu veux
tu
veux pe mosqué un petite
[Musique]
ruine toi moi je je serais resté en haut
non non non non non non non non non non
pas du tout c'est joli ça doucement
doucement doucement tu peux faire ça
faut le faire doucement sinon on s' ser
voilà c'est parti c'est
parti pe pot à droite sur les
bateaux à droite vas-y à
droitea pas fait ça mais ouais moi non
plus ou ou une connerie c'est une
connerie des bateau je pensais il y des
gens devant nous regarde regarde devant
nous regarde regarde des gens qui
prennent le bac
doucement doucement c'est bon je bien je
suis d'accord avec toi jeis d'accord je
suis d'accord je suis d'accord c'est bon
c'est bon je reconnais je
reconnais qu'attendre le bateau toi pour
traverser puis regarde tous les linges
là-bas qui se bien vu
bravo du L croyais que c'était les gens
qui attendaient pour un Batt c'est joli
ça comme tu regarde regarde c'est joli
ça fait rentrer un aigle dans le champ
ouais
il est passé
merci je te fais
rentrer écoute bien les enfants vous qui
vont écouter
ça c'est pour ça qu' entendu entendu
parler en fin de compte
nonés c'est
bonend okand Iland ils vont entendre al
là ça encore pire que tout bouge
pas
stop vas-y coupe allez attends attends
ah oui ça tape ça tap c'est beau ça
c'est be ça et ça tap la vache Vy tap
mer
arrê
non je crois
pas c'est parti elle a son pil en la
main allez 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 oh 8 9
10 alle c'est bon ah
bon allez allez is allez c'est parti
voilà c'est
parti
allez allez allez les
filles il y a le filet me qui travaille
avec des filets et tout essaie
de moi je récadrai tu vois entre le mec
de filet à gauche et le pilon à
droite pardon vas-y vas-y lae vas-y je
récarderai tu vois
les il est presque il est presque
les
enfants